No creo que tengas ningún motivo para seguir esta guía práctica,
pero hoy te vamos a dar los pasos que tienes que seguir
para poner en riesgo tu vida en un campo de fútbol.
Bueno, chozas, esto es una guía práctica en la que no hay nadie muerto, tranquilos,
y por eso hemos puesto el casi en el título delante de perder,
porque es una guía práctica para aprender cómo casi perder la vida en un estadio.
Y sobre todo para que no nos lo mate el algoritmo, ¿no?
Para que YouTube no diga, ¡hey!
Cuidado, cuidado.
A tomar por culo tu vida y todo.
Cuidado.
Tengo que decir que para chequear cómo trata el algoritmo
al tema de las palabras como muerte y todo esto,
bueno, metí la palabra en YouTube,
me salió todo cosas religiosas y filosóficas.
Ah, bueno, claro, es verdad, claro.
Pero con un chorro de visitas.
Sí, claro.
Chorro de visitas.
¿Qué hay después de la muerte y cosas así?
No, no, directamente, no sé, vídeos muy...
No sé, no sé, que descubrí que hay mucha gente monetizando a Jesucristo.
¡Hostia!
La leche, una cosa...
Lo cual es grave.
Es grave.
Hombre, se enterá a Jesucristo y te hace...
Es bastante grave.
Se llama blasfemar eso.
Bueno, amigos, lo que no va a ser desde luego una blasfemia
es esta guía práctica en la que, como os decimos, pues...
hay a vosotros, pero, bueno, si alguno ha tenido la duda alguna vez de
oye, ¿cómo podría correr riesgo en mi vida en un campo de fútbol?
Pues vamos a dar varios pasos
siempre basándonos en cosas que han sucedido en el fútbol inglés.
Así que, Chozas, pues te voy a contar varias historias que he ido encontrando.
Yo vengo a ciegas, vengo a ciegas.
Te aviso, amigo, que estás al otro lado.
Casi todas las historias son sobre la Non League.
¡Uuuh!
A ver, claro, lógicamente...
Ni fútbol profesional ni nada.
Claro, los profesionales creo que...
por lo menos en los estadios hay un pelín de seguridad.
Luego llega la Non League y...
Pero vamos a empezar con la Premier League, porque...
el primer consejo de esta guía práctica es que te tires en paracaídas.
Hombre, a ver, empezamos bien.
Es lógico, si te tires en paracaídas tienes más posibilidades de morirte
que si estás ahora mismo sentado aquí.
¿En qué vídeo lo sacamos esto?
En el vídeo de los recién ascendidos.
De por qué se van a salvar.
Ya os hablamos de aquel paracaidista de un espectáculo
que hizo prepartido el Burnley en un partido contra el Ipswich Town,
que acabó con el Ipswich Town ganando 3-0
y el partido pospuesto durante una hora.
Os dejamos el vídeo por aquí arriba, pero no.
Esto no va sobre ese paracaidista.
Ahora, os tengo que reconocer que ha sido uno de los casos
que nos ha dado pie a este vídeo.
Nos vamos a una historia aún peor,
que es la del 13 de diciembre de 1998.
Chozas, ese día, Aston Villa y Arsenal se enfrentan en Premier League
y el Aston Villa prepara como espectáculo para el descanso
una lluvia de Santa Claus, una lluvia de papás noeles.
Bien.
Empieza mal la historia.
La idea era que para celebrar un poco la Navidad
descendiesen del cielo muchos Santa Claus y aterrizasen en el campo.
Pero la tarde se fue complicando, ya estaba todo perfectamente montado
y se levantó un viento que era para verlo.
Muy complicado.
¿Venían con los renos o Santa Claus?
No, no, los renos dijeron, ya vuelas tú, monstruo,
porque aquí hay una ventisca del copón.
Bueno, fue entonces cuando nuestro amigo Nigel Rogoff,
paracaidista del ejército británico, no era ningún novato,
chocó con uno de los tejados de la grada desviado por ese viento
y cayó desde esa altura en un lateral de la pista
que rodeaba el césped de Villa Park.
Como podéis ver aquí en estas imágenes
del accidente gravísimo.
Inmediatamente después de este accidente, por megafonía,
se avisó a todos los paracaidistas que venían detrás de Nigel
que intentasen aterrizar en cualquier sitio,
menos en el centro del campo,
para evitar así más acumulación de paracaidistas en la zona.
Yo sé que estás a medio camino de ¿me río o no me río?
porque no sé si este tío se ha matado.
Hombre, no, porque el título pone casi.
A ver, os tengo que decir que las cosas como son,
ya os voy avisando, esto fue una cosa bastante grave,
pero tuvo un final feliz, así que quedaos conmigo.
Villa Park ya sabéis que está rodeado de casas,
de una autopista y un parque en el que supongo que
no vieron muy factible aterrizar.
Así que los paracaidistas que venían detrás de nuestro amigo Nigel Rogoff
tuvieron que aterrizar reparteos entre las porterías, los corners,
todo lo que fuera, esquivar el centro del campo
para ayudar a los servicios a atender a nuestro amigo Nigel.
Bueno, insisto, esto fue serio,
porque Rogoff se lo tuvieron que llevar al hospital
a una operación a vida o muerte.
Cayó a plomo desde el techo de una de las gradas.
Es una caída que leía un aficionado que daba sus declaraciones
después de este partido, es más o menos como caerte desde un segundo piso.
Te puedes matar perfectamente.
Bueno, sobrevivió a una caída que habría matado a mucha gente
y las lesiones le provocaron la amputación de una pierna.
Y dices, hostia, hostia Nacho, ¿cómo has elegido esta historia?
Bueno, es una historia, amigos, que tú deciros que tiene un final
para sacar una sonrisa.
Y hasta cierto punto, yo creo que mi amigo Nigel, porque es amigo,
creo que también piensa que todo pasa por algo.
Porque resulta, amigo chozas, que durante su rehabilitación,
ya con la pierna amputada, conoció a Sara,
una de las enfermeras que lo ayudó.
Se enamoraron y tuvieron dos gemelos.
Bravo, bravo, viva el amor.
Joder, hostia, claro, ya lo de la amputación de la pierna he dicho,
hostia, muy serio esto ya.
Y no solo eso, porque además me gusta la gente que tiene humor
para afrontar estas cosas, es un tipo que ha logrado varias gestas benéficas
como formar parte de la primera expedición de hombres con miembros amputados
que cruzan el océano a remo.
Y es un grupo, es una embarcación solo formada por gente que tiene
como mínimo una pierna amputada.
Y entre todos cruzaron el océano atlántico a remo.
Pero lo mejor es cómo se llama ese grupo de hombres.
Se hacen llamar cuatro hombres, tres piernas.
Vas a ver por qué.
¡Fíjalo!
Son cuatro hombres, pero efectivamente solo hay tres piernas.
Nuestro amigo Nigel, que sepáis que es el segundo por la derecha.
El calvo con barba, que me cae fantásticamente bien.
¡Hombre, claro!
¡Véalo!
¡Véalo qué te pasa!
Y el otro levantando sus piernas.
El nombre de cuatro hombres, tres piernas me parece una auténtica genialidad.
Y por cierto, a la hora de buscar este foto, he puesto lo de, en inglés,
cuatro hombres, tres piernas.
Me ha salido el caso de un señor que nació con tres piernas y una cosa...
Hacía muchos años y que debían usarlo ahí como...
Como una atracción.
Sí, en la época en la que no se respetaba mucho a la gente
que tenía malformaciones y tal.
¡Hostia, chaval!
Y me he quedado también un poco impactado.
Sí, esta imagen has preferido no ponerla.
Ahí está nuestro amigo Nigel.
Como varón, me molesta que no hagan referencia a sus partes en algún momento.
Ya, ya, ya.
Me molesta.
Bueno, oye, después del grave accidente, las partes de nuestro amigo Nigel
siguieron funcionando y ahí está la historia con Sara.
Salieron para que os hagáis una idea y tienen relación con España
desde San Sebastián de la Gomera, en las Canarias,
y llegaron hasta Antigua y Barbuda,
todo remando durante cuarenta y pico días.
Un momento.
O un mínimo con una pierna.
¿Qué?
Pero...
¿Qué es una barbaridad?
No estaba ubicando...
Yo me imaginaba...
Que el Océano Atlántico...
Un cruzar, yo qué sé, el estrecho o algo así.
Cuarenta y pico días.
Pero qué puto zumbado.
Y ando con una pierna o ninguna.
Que sí, que sí, que sí.
Hombre, pesas menos.
Ah, ahora...
Bueno, ya, hombre.
A la hora de remar.
Sí, claro, no se ha jodido.
Ah, no, ahora va a ser una ventaja, José Alberto Chozas.
Ahora va a ser una ventaja.
A ver, la cabeza se la dejó tocada, el laos que está.
Bueno, ya ves que el tío es un ejemplo de superación.
Madre de Dios.
Además, también he querido recoger unas declaraciones del Guardian, en las que nuestro
amigo Nigel se tomó...
Porque siempre empiezo con nuestro amigo Nigel, pero es nuestro amigo.
Se tomó con humor su accidente y dijo, pido perdón a la gente que estaba en Villa Park
porque fueron a ver un partido de fútbol y acabaron viendo a la madre navidad rebotando
contra el tejado de su estadio.
Hombre, es verdad que...
Tela.
No hemos terminado...
Vale, se lo toma bien.
Se lo toma bien.
Tuvo dos hijos a raíz del accidente.
Genial.
Hay razones para sonreír por mucho que lo me he perdido una pierna.
Este tío cuando entra en el ejército si alguien le dice que iba a perder una pierna
en Villa Park...
Vestido de Santa Claus.
Hostias.
De Papa Noel.
No pensé yo que esto iba a salir así para un veterano de guerra.
¿Creéis que hemos terminado con el paracaidismo de Inglaterra?
No.
Esta es una historia sin lesiones, pero que también quiero que veáis.
Hablamos del partido entre el Salisbury City y el Chester de 2013.
Chozas, lo que viene a continuación, quiero que lo veas.
Se está desarrollando el juego con total normalidad.
Atención porque hay un ataque ahí por el centro del campo, un regatito, un cambio de
ritmo.
Ahí un poquito que si tal, los moraos...
Ahí va.
Perdona, ¿qué?
Hola, chavales.
Mira la gente.
Me encanta la gente.
Los aficionados de Salisbury City.
Se la apela.
Ovación cerrada.
Ovación cerrada al paracaidista.
Buenas tardes.
Yo me iba, eh.
Yo me estaba yendo.
Como si no hubiera pasado nada.
Vosotros seguid a lo vuestro.
Al jugador al que se le está cayendo un poquito y tal.
No, pero que se le está cayendo un poquito el paracaidista y se piensa que le va a caer
encima la torre Eiffel.
No me jodas.
Bueno, pues ya lo puedes quitar si quieres, Jesús.
Ahí tenemos al Liniers completamente impactado.
Este hombre formaba parte de un evento benéfico de paracaidistas, pero se encontró con nubes
bajas y perdió la referencia del aeródromo en el que tenía que aterrizar.
Así que cuando volvió a recuperar cierta visibilidad, solo vio un campo de fútbol
y dijo...
Allá que voy.
Yo sé que esté jugando la jornada del fin de semana, pero me toca.
No había otro momento para aterrizar que justo donde estaba jugando.
Ya veis que las dos aficiones lo ovacionaron.
La policía, por cierto, se lo dijo por interrogarlo y se marchó sin cargos.
Muy bien la policía aquí también.
Claro, ¿qué iba a decir el muchacho?
Pues no, no he sido un terrorista.
Es que me he perdido con las nubes.
Me he perdido con las nubes.
Iba a decir habría estado guapo, no habría estado guapo, pero joder que el tío bajé
con un ametrallista, con un paracaídas.
No habría estado guapo.
Claro, por eso digo, iba a decir habría estado guapo, pero no habría estado.
O sea, habría estado guapo en una película.
José Alberto Chozas, habría estado guapo que aterrizase en el campo con un ametrallista.
Ese macho.
Yo en Valdemoro no sé las cosas que vivís, pero macho, os dejan muy tocado.
Vamos con el siguiente consejo.
El primero era tírate en paracaídas, el segundo es tírate unos petarditos, hombre.
Cuidado con el doble significado de esto.
En Valdemoro sí que te digo que tirarte unos petardos puede ser otra cosa.
Ya, ya, ya.
Bueno, significado global, ¿vale?
Vamos a ver si manejamos las acepciones que están recogidas por la Real Academia Española.
A ver, la primera de todas es una cosa seria, pero insisto, no murió nadie.
Entonces, bueno, tampoco hubo lesiones muy graves.
Hay una señora que sí que tuvo un tema en la cara, pero no más que una herida aparatosa.
Pero os tengo que contar que los Wolverhampton Wanderers vuelven a escena por una razón que no les gustaría.
Porque un espectáculo pirotécnico prepartido en 2003 en el Molineo antes de un Wolf New Castle,
que por si no es suficiente castigo irá a ver un Wolf New Castle encima, te tiene que pasar esto.
También te digo, de Chiripa está aquí la camiseta del New Castle de un vídeo que hemos hecho antes.
Se ha quedado aquí de Chiripa, parecen.
Pero esto no es culpa del New Castle, esto es culpa de los Wolves.
Porque amigos, en ese espectáculo pirotécnico resulta que varios fuegos artificiales salieron disparados
en horizontal en vez de vertical.
¡Hor-quida!
Claro, es el ABC de un fuego artificial.
El fuego artificial va hacia arriba, porque si va hacia los lados...
Se estrella contra alguien.
...se lia la de Cristo. Bueno, se lió la de Cristo.
Hasta ocho aficionados que estaban en la grada salieron heridos por esos proyectiles que salieron en horizontal.
Y el feo por aquella época de los Wolverhampton Wanderers, Jess Moxey,
dijo que puedo confirmar sin lugar a dudas que no habrá más espectáculos en el Molineo.
Porque no hemos matado a alguien de milagro.
Imagínate tú ahí en el asiento del Molineo, a fuegos artificiales, ¡pum! en la cara.
La madre que me parió.
Puedo confirmar sin lugar a dudas.
¡Hombre, hombre! Gracias, Jess.
Gracias, Jess. Te lo agradezco.
Menos mal que no te quedan dudas.
Es verdad que no ha vuelto a haber espectáculo en el Molineo.
Bueno, el tema es que los Wolves no han aprendido demasiado.
Porque en 2019, como ya has visto en la imagen, que les gusta tirar fueguitos y cosas así y tal,
que es ante ayer, durante un espectáculo pirotécnico, mira lo que pasó.
No dieron a nadie los cohetes.
Pero mira el techo, mira el techo de la grada.
Todo muy guapo, tal.
¡Uay! Inpectacular.
¡Pim! ¡Vámonos!
Oye, de verdad.
¡Ahhh!
¡Lo aprenden!
¡Mira, mira, mira!
Pero qué cojones, la hostia, qué pega.
Es increíble.
Pero hostia, en 16 años no han sido capaces de mejorar algo.
¡La caballero!
Bueno sí, que ahora se estrellan contra arriba y no contra las personas.
¡Algo mejorado!
¡Hombre, mismo club!
¡Joder, cabal!
Hombre, a ver, prefiero esto a que lo tienes en horizontal.
Esto es verdad.
Que no es tan difícil apuntar unos fogos artificiales.
Hostia.
Joder.
Bueno, este era un vídeo de Jack Patterson 36, sacado de Twitter.
Pero no es el caso más grave de Petardos, porque aquí sí que todo que hablaros de un subnormal, un salvaje,
pero gracias a Dios la policía supo quién fue.
Y lo más importante, el implicado no recibió ningún daño.
Y por tanto no lo podemos tomar como se lo tomó su club, que es, bueno, lo denunció, pero también en un tono agradable.
Pero amigos, hay algo peor, aunque es cuando los Petardos son dirigidos a un futbolista,
que es lo que pasó en el partido de Hashtag United y Conor Rangers, cuando vais a ver que sucedió esto.
Y el implicado fue el bueno de Matas Skrna.
Vamos a ver la jugada, todo sucedía con normalidad y de repente la madre que me parió.
Fíjate el comentarista de Hashtag United alucinando Matas Skrna, que va al suelo,
porque en ese momento es una mezcla de...
Que te ha dejado...
La han abrasado y la pega uno.
Te ha dejado completamente noqueado el ruido, más el golpe en ese momento de lo que tú dices,
de casi que te abrasa el tobillo.
Bueno, os insisto en que Matas no estaba bien, lo dijo el club, y que no le había pasado nada grave,
pero si el vídeo va de casi palmarla en el estadio, la leche esto había que meterlo.
Hombre, un poco más arriba, igual le hace un destrozo, que además eso va a velocidad.
La madre que lo parió, el payaso ese.
Espero que no haya vuelto a entrar en un campo de fútbol.
Insisto en la denuncia de este subnormal, que la policía se hizo cargo de él, pero joder,
la nonlig, ¿eh?
Joder, la nonlig.
Hostia, tú estás un sábado tranquilamente jugando a las 8 de la tarde en un polo,
perdido de Dios, y recibes un petardazo.
Petardazo en el tobillo.
Menos mal que fue en el tobillo.
Cuidao un poco más arriba.
Hombre, llega rebotado un poco más.
Un poco más arriba y te jode la vida.
Y esa tula no vuelve a funcionar.
Ese no tiene gemelo ya.
Otro de los consejos que tenemos para este vídeo,
y que tiene mucho que ver con la nonlig, es meterse con los tipos duros.
Amigos, si quieres morir en un campo de fútbol, métete con la gente equivocada.
¿Cómo fue el caso de un partido en 2024 en el que dos jugadores del Villariki Town
se pusieron a dar toques delante de Tom Derri, delantero del Folkestone invicta,
mientras estaba el partido parado?
Hasta que Tom dijo basta.
Vamos a ver la jugada.
Ahí tenemos la atención médica y los dos jugadores del Villariki Town
pues hay un poquito de...
¡Ay, un que no caiga!
¡Eh, mira!
Ahora va el calvo y hace otra vez...
Tom pide el balón.
¡Eh, que no!
Y mira, mira, Tom...
¡Eh, que sí!
Toma, claro.
Bueno, bueno, y encima le agarra.
Se está cagando.
Toma por culo el balón.
Y el árbitro, Toma por culo a Tom.
¡A tomar por culo a Tom!
¡No, le expulsa!
¡Le expulsa a Tom!
Pero, no, hombre, es injustísimo.
Estupefacción.
Pero que le están vacilando entre dos.
Están haciendo que no caiga encima de su cabeza.
El tío quería el balón y una vez que ya salte con el balón, lo saca él.
Ya me he chinado.
Toma por culo.
El partido vosotros y yo.
Dadme una notita zapatada.
No es premium.
Pero un 8.
Se queda corto.
Ya que le vas a dar y te van a expulsar, hostia, mételo un bueno, hostia.
Buena patada.
Bueno, es un vídeo de Ben Robinson 7-7-0.
Y es un vídeo que, bueno, al menos implica una pelea entre iguales, en cierto modo.
Suspecho que lo que viene ahora no va a ser entre iguales.
Lo que viene a continuación, Chozas, es de lo más escalofriante que se ha publicado
nunca en la media inglesa.
Hostia.
Nos vamos más abajo en la pirámide del fútbol inglés.
Pero ¿puedo reírme?
Claro.
Te puedes reír, pero que sepas que aquí estamos sentando en el territorio de los niños,
de la infancia.
El jodido si me río.
Partido entre los Surrey Caswells y el AFC-Ewell.
2024.
Y sucede esto.
Atento.
Ojo a ese niño, ojo a ese niño engorilao, ojo a ese niño engorilao.
La liamos.
Pero que no se acerca él.
Mira el niño, mira el niño.
Un momento, pero el niño está como si nada.
Está como nuevo.
Le había perdido la pista.
De hecho, el niño quiere seguir jugando.
No, no, el niño.
Otra vez lo vamos a volver a ver.
El niño quiere la revancha.
Hombre, el niño también, alguien le tenía que decir que...
¡Uy!
¡Ay, pero que!
Pero que el cabrón del niño se pone a jugar.
El taquel.
Claro, claro.
El taquel, el taquel es duro.
Hombre, el 17 el que le hace el taquel, si no pesa como 15 veces el niño, no pesa nada.
Mira qué pecho latón que tiene el tío.
Está entrao, eh.
Bueno, escalofriante, eh.
Sin duda alguna.
Nada te podía preparar para este vídeo.
Absolutamente nada.
El niño sale como una rosa.
A mí me hace esa entrada y mido metro y medio más que el niño y me deja tieso.
El niño se quedó tranquilo porque no tuvo ninguna lesión pobre.
Que hostias.
No se vuelve a hacer...
Bueno, no se vuelve a acercar, ¿no?
Porque se ha vuelto a acercar.
Ya le suda tres cojones al puto niño.
Bueno, luego he leído alguna declaración postpartido y no sé quién era, si el club
del jugador que le hace el taquel o del otro club, pero diciendo, oye, tenemos un equipo
de niños, le queremos fichar, eh.
Porque el chaval tiene predisposiciones para ir al...
También te digo, típica historia que dentro de 15 años es jugador en Champions League
y sale, ¿os acordáis de cuando?
Pues es el...
Por supuesto.
Seguro.
Era yo, era yo, era yo.
En fin, la Noon League es que ya sabéis que, bueno, es un fútbol maravilloso que os recomiendo
siempre visitar allí donde vayáis, pero bueno, pues también tiene sus tortas.
De hecho, había historias, hace poco hubo una historia entre el Avro FC y el Kids Growth
Athletic que se empezaron a hostear entre aficionados y jugadores porque había en la
grada, grada, que ya ves.
Sí, bueno.
Los asientos de cemento.
Se empezaron a pelear un directivo con un aficionado, el portero le soltó una...
No es ni mucho menos la tónica habitual de la Noon League, pero para aquí veáis la
de cosas que he encontrado en Internet.
Pero de eso no hay imágenes que eso es una salvajada y el fútbol no va de eso.
Vamos con la siguiente, el siguiente consejo de esta guía práctica.
Me intriga esta.
Y es pedir agüita.
Creo que esta es la que más te va a gustar.
Y tú, a su momento, ¿cómo que implica un riesgo para tu vida?
¿Pedir agüita en un campo de fútbol?
Pues tendrías que preguntarle a Adam Dodd y lo que le pasó en el partido entre el Bumber
Bridge y el Basfor United en 2024.
Chozas, muy atento a lo que va a suceder ante tus ojos.
Madre de Dios.
Pero, pero ¿qué haces?
Pero no ha visto.
Creo que la repetición te das cuenta en la reacción del de la botella, diciendo, eh,
yo se la he tirado.
¿Qué quieres que haga?
Y coge el genio y se pone a beber agua.
Y se pone a beber agua.
Pero, tío, ¿pero que lo has noqueado?
¿Qué le has partido la nariz?
A Adam Dodd, que no sabe en ese momento ni en qué día de la semana está.
Le han cambiado, han cambiado el cerebro entero por otro.
Este vídeo lo ve Rudagoni.
Es increíble.
Mira, mira, mira, mira.
¡Po!
De hecho, tío, me suena haberlo visto en Rudagoni, eh.
Sí, tío, pero que el tío se ha quedado bebiendo tan tranquilo.
Tranquilo, eres un cabrón.
El que va a preocuparse es el otro.
Y mirando al estrellador al lado diciendo, pues vaya hostia, le he soltado la estrella
del equipo.
Es un vídeo que no puedo dejar de ver.
Tiene un punto hasta adictivo.
A ver, Jesús.
¿Puedes disfrutarlo una última vez?
¡Pimba!
¡Joder!
¿Cómo le rebota la cabeza hacia atrás al pobre hombre?
Cuidado.
Dicho esto, insisto.
¡Toma!
¡Toda la gente!
¡Es verdad!
Ya dejó en bucle.
Por cierto, hay un vídeo que me ha gustado mucho.
Por cierto, hay un tío lesionado detrás.
¡Eso da igual!
Ahora hay dos lesiones.
Tengo que decir que creo que era el community manager del Bashfor United que en el momento
en el que sucede, él no se da cuenta de lo que ha pasado y pone un tweet diciendo,
hay un jugador del Bumber Bridge que está en el suelo, si no está rodeado por nadie.
No sé qué le ha pasado.
Claro, como para adivinarlo.
Joder.
Dicho esto, ese impacto, esa botella en la cara sin verla venir, debe hacer un daño.
Hostia, no, no.
Un daño.
En la napia, un cortesito, ese R7 te hace…
Impresionante.
No lo veas, no pideis agua si no queréis que vuestra vida corra peligro en un campo
de fútbol.
Vamos con más consejos.
El siguiente es meterte donde no te llaman.
Efectivamente, también es el ABC de una persona que quiere poner en riesgo su vida en un campo
de fútbol.
¿Cómo es el caso del partido entre Mad Lock Town y Lancaster City de abril de este año?
De esto, pues que vas a ver al equipo de tu pueblo.
Yo voy al Jovem que viene.
Espero que no pase lo mismo que el Inter de Valde Moro.
Era Inter, no?
Sí, Inter de Valde Moro.
Espero que no pase lo mismo porque vas a ver al equipo y que a lo mejor estás en tu sitio
y te atropellan, que fue el caso del estadio de Mad Lock Town.
Aquí tenéis a este Alfa que no sé en qué momento confundió la autopista con la entrada
del estadio, pero en pleno partido se coló un coche.
Que tuvieron que escoltar los guardias de seguridad con esta actitud de a mí por esto
no me pagaron.
Esto, honestamente, no va en mi sueldo.
¿Qué cojones hacía un coche en mitad del partido?
Ojalá sea una afición de hecha.
¡Que no encontraba aparcamiento, coño!
¡Me he perdido el inicio!
¡He aparcado!
¡Aquí!
Es el puto Marinakis.
Ese es el siguiente paso de Marinakis.
Se sube al parque y dice, ¡ahí lo dejó!
¡Me lo aparcas, Nuno!
¡Yo no estoy en uno!
¡Anche!
¡Sóndate!
¡Me lo aparcas!
¿Por qué hablas así, Marinakis?
En fin, no es el único que se metió donde no lo llamaban porque también encontraba
una historia.
Y aquí sí vamos al fútbol profesional y no sólo de sugo, vamos a un partido de Champions
League.
Esta a lo mejor la conocen los aficionados de Manchester United, pero en 2001, antes de
un partido de Champions entre Manchester United y Bayern Munich en Munich,
¡Coño!
Son dos clubes.
Antísimo nivel.
Un tarado especializado en meterse en eventos deportivos y hacer de espontáneo llamado
Karl Power se metió en la foto de equipo de los Red Devils en un momento que dejó
una foto para la historia.
Esta.
¿Cómo veis?
Ahí hay una alineación indebida del Manchester United porque son 12 jugadores y el de la
izquierda es Karl Power.
Un hombre que también, como podéis averiguar, ya ha sido detectado por Roy Keane y por esto
lo incluido a la hora de hablar de riesgos para perder la vida.
Roy Keane va a asesinar a Carlitos Poderoso.
Lo va a asesinar, lo va a matar, lo va a descuartizar.
Mientras, por cierto, tengo que decir que Andy Cole está el tío...
En sí mismo.
Está tan digno diciendo, yo no sé quién coño es este tío, pero voy a hacer como
que no ha pasado nada.
Absolutamente en sí mismo.
¿Qué se le pasa por la cabeza a Roy Keane en el momento en el que detesta a este tío?
Lo mato y me como sus vísceras en una barbacoa.
También te digo, ¿cómo se ha dado cuenta?
Está todo el mundo mirando al frente y Roy Keane ya ha detectado algo que no le cuadra.
Ha visto que esa fila es demasiado larga.
Luego está Dwight York mirando a Bartez como diciendo, esto no es serio, Fabián, esto
era la Champions.
Yo pensaba que esto era serio.
Oye, el tío...
Joder.
Genio, eh.
Genio absoluto.
O sea, si no conocieras a los futbolistas dices, ¿quién coño es el impostor?
¿Quién es el impostor?
Y tú dirás, ¿qué viene uniformado?
En buena forma, el tío, además.
¿Qué viene uniformado está?
Bueno, te cuento la historia.
El tarado de Carlitos Poderoso, Carl Power, viajó a Múnich haciéndose pasar por periodista.
Se enteró en el hotel de concentración del color que iba a vestir ese día al Manchester
United porque se llevó las tres equipaciones completas y preguntó a un miembro del staff
y le dijo, sí, sí, jugamos de blanco.
Bien, entró haciéndose pasar por periodista en el estadio, se puso la equipación entera,
la blanca, debajo de un chándal y se colocó a pie de campo aprovechando su acreditación
al lado de los fotógrafos.
En el momento en que se hicieron la foto, dejó una imagen para la historia porque eso sí,
a este tío luego le pegarán una sanción de copón económica, no podrá volver a entrar
en el estadio de fútbol, lo que tú quieras, pero él tiene una foto que nosotros no tenemos.
Esta foto es para el salón.
O sea, de verdad, me parece...
Me parece una obra maestra, tío.
O sea, de verdad que me parece acojonante.
O sea, que nadie se dé cuenta de que te estás poniendo la puta foto.
Bueno, sí, Roy King.
Increíble.
Y la foto también me dices al fotógrafo que dijo...
Sí, sí, maravilloso.
Yo la tiro.
No deberías estar haciendo esa foto, pero la tiro.
Porque la verdad es que el tío tira un par de huevos.
Yo la tiro.
Joder.
A ver, sanción económica, quiero decir, el tío se ha puesto en una foto, tampoco ha
hecho...
Entonces, te quiero recordar que esto que está haciendo es un delito.
Delito leve.
En mis libros, delito leve.
Delito leve o grave, esto es un delito.
Delito leve, levísimo.
Levísimo.
Hacerte una foto con tus ídolos.
Bueno, si quieres, buscas en Google...
El speed de la época.
Bueno, es que el tío no se dejó un evento deportivo por colarse.
Creo que se coló en la Fórmula 1, se coló en el Cricket...
Estamos hablando de un auténtico genio, o sea, un genio de película.
Sí, un puto tarado, un puto tarado, de kilo.
Para mí es un genio.
Vamos a terminar con el último consejo de todos de esta guía práctica, amigos.
Claro, si quieres morir en el campo, pues también es un buen consejo que juegues hasta
palmarla.
Y aquí vamos a contar una historia bastante rocambolesca que implica a otro equipo de
la Nonleague.
Porque hablamos del Truro City, amigos.
La historia del Truro City es acojonante y muy reciente.
Ha llegado el momento de contarla, macho.
Llevas semanas, incluso meses, diría, esperando contarla.
La voy a resumir mucho, pero lo suficiente como para que veáis que tenía que entrar
en este vídeo.
Porque lo extraño es que sobreviviese toda la plantilla a lo que vivieron.
El Truro City, en 2024, al final de temporada tuvo que jugar, escúchame bien, tú que estás
al otro lado, 13 partidos en 28 días.
13 partidos en 28 días.
Casi un partido cada dos días.
Uno sí, uno no.
Prácticamente.
Del 23 de marzo al 20 de abril de 2024 jugaron 13 partidos, con 3 victorias, 5 empates y
5 derrotas.
Bastante que ganaron 3 partidos, macho.
Mira la cara de susto del de la izquierda, que es el del Truro City, diciendo, pero
ya he perdido la afición al fútbol.
Me quiero dedicar a ser contable que para lo que he estudiado.
Contra este tío no jugué hace 5 días.
Veo más al pavo éste que a mi madre.
No, madre que me parió.
Te explico.
Como estaban terminando, porque no solo esto, es luego donde jugaron, estaban terminando
las obras de su nuevo estadio.
Por tanto empezaron la temporada compartiendo campo con el Plymouth Parkway.
Vale.
Pero sufrieron una serie de aplazamientos por el mal tiempo y por tanto el mal estado
del campo.
Así que se marcharon al estadio del Town Town Town.
Que me encanta el nombre.
Town Town Town.
Parece de coña, pero no.
Es el Town Town Town.
Ha habido nombres extraños en este vídeo, pero el Town Town Town.
Town Town Town.
Bien.
Volvieron a tener problemas en el estadio del Town Town Town con las condiciones meteorológicas.
Es gente ya oficialmente hasta los huevos.
Bien.
Entonces pasaron a jugar en el estadio del Gloucester City.
Ya son 3 estadios que no son el suyo.
¿Por qué no pueden jugar en el suyo que están obras?
E incluso todo esto es por aplazamientos, por mal tiempo, no se puede jugar, el estado
del terreno no juega esta falta, porque tú en la Premier League puedes jugar, nieve,
truene o se caiga un meteorito.
Porque los campos, el agua la drenan, que da gusto verlo, pero nunca pueden.
Sí, claro, ahí ya...
Eso es un barrizal.
Eso es un barrizal que a veces es impracticable.
Bien, pues incluso cuando pudieron jugar algunos de esos partidos, también vivieron
un aplazamiento por una lesión grave de rodilla de un jugador y porque llegaron los médicos
y demás tuvieron que aplazar el partido.
Que ya es como decir un momento, para un día que no llueve, no truena, no lleva.
Entonces se lesionó este tío y también lo aplazamos.
¿Era del Truro?
No, creo que era de Lisbon Borov, el jugador.
Hombre, si era del Truro, ¿tiene explicación que el pobre hombre se haya roto la rodilla?
¿Entonces era el otro no?
No tiene ningún tipo de explicación.
¿Qué pasó con esta gente?
Claro, cuando empezaron la racha, porque la temporada no se podía alargar, esos partidos
había que jugarlos en ese espacio de tiempo.
Claro, claro.
No podías alargarlo porque el resto de equipos dirían, bueno, yo no tengo mis planes, o
¿no?
¿No es viable?
Bien, pues cuando empezaron esa racha, claro, tenían tantos partidos menos que estaban
hundidos en el descenso.
Tú empezabas viendo la clasificación con la presión de decir, hay que sacar al equipo
del descenso.
Pero al mismo tiempo dices, hombre, es que técnicamente tengo nueve partidos menos que
el resto de fulanos, diez partidos menos.
Bueno, pues acabaron décimos sextos y se salvaron.
¿Pero cómo afrontas?
Ya mismo.
Es que técnicamente tú ahora mismo, quítale a un equipo de la Premier League las próximas
diez jornadas.
¿Dónde va a estar?
Va a estar hundido en el descenso.
Tú imagínate, para la psicología del jugador es decir, hay que sacar al equipo del descenso.
Tú, vaya huevos gordos.
¡La locura!
Trece partidos en 28 días.
Recortaron, claro, tres victorias, cinco empates, son 14 puntos.
Imagínate.
O sea, recortaron una barbaridad.
14 puntos.
Joder, guay.
Quítales 14 puntos en la tabla.
Y estaban, y claro, y dices, no hay manera de salvarme.
Y luego decimos sextos.
Ni tan mal.
Hostia, macho.
Vaya genio.
Y no murió ninguno.
Acabaron todos abotados.
No, es verdad.
Pero no murió ninguno.
Bueno, de las rodillas le murió la rodilla, pero...
Sí, sí, sí, pero bueno, son cosas que pasan en el fútbol.
Joder.
Bueno, amigos, pues hasta aquí un breve repaso a consejos que os damos y lo que queréis,
por lo que sea, es casi palmarla en un estadio de fútbol.
Que nos cuente la gente, historias parecidas que hayan vivido, ¿no?
Sí, claro.
Y un chico en su aterrizón para que esté en la terraza mientras tomaban el sol.
Y dicho, contadnos historias verídicas, no las inventéis.
Sí, me estaría mal, ¿no?
Y a lo mejor sale videíto reaccionando para miembros.
Puede ser.
Puede salir videíto.
Puede ser, pero que necesitamos sinceridad.
Y si os ha gustado el vídeo, pues dejadnos un like y...
Swipe and hype.
Swipe and hype, que es desliza, no sé hacia qué lado siquiera, que se hace a la derecha
en la sección de comentarios en el móvil.
El caso es que si lo hypeas, pues nos da más visibilidad a YouTube.
Y estos vídeos que no van sobre el Manchester United ni el Liverpool ni el Arsenal, pues
se ven menos.
Sí, es la realidad.
Se ven menos.
Los que más molen son los que ven menos de la gente.
Pues eso, por si te apetece.
Y nada, nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.
Y si te apetece también, ¿eh?
Y al estadio vea pasártelo bien.
No hacer el capullo tirando petardos.
Capullo.
¡Vamos a ganar!